バンカラジオ今日は導の倒し方を勉強して
いくぞ俺は天才小学生天の俺にとって学校
の授業は簡単すぎてつまらないし他の生徒
の知能レベルも低すぎてうんざりするだ
から俺は決めたんだ絶対にずる休みして
やる極限病作戦病使い学校を休むという
至ってシンプルな作戦
だこれで完璧だ
お母さん熱れたから学校休み
たいあらすごい高熱じゃないおでこ触らせ
なさいちょっとなんで触らせないのよいや
その触ら
せろ
うええ
[音楽]
え熱の割にはよく動けるじゃないよこれで
も
くらえほお
わ
くっそどこ
だ誰か
わこ
[音楽]
ダメたっ
たさんどうぞ
はいそれじゃあインフルエンザの検査し
ますねはいちょっと痛いです
[音楽]
よ
この綿棒はさっきインフルエンザと思わ
れる患者の使用済ティッシュからウイルス
を抽出した
ものすいませんはいはい
はい妖精反応が出るはず妖精ですね照明書
出しておきます
よっしゃこれを先生に出せ
[音楽]
ば先生インフルエンザにかかってしまった
ので今日は学校休めます偶然なら実は先生
もインフルエンザなんだ
え他の生徒も全員フルだったらしいつまり
映る心配なし授業せ
[音楽]
だなんでこうなるんだ
よこうなったら本当に風を引いて学校を
休んで
やる
おやああ
あ
寒いれん
でんでんれん
でんでん
お母さん寝れたから学校休みたいあた
あんたとんでもない高熱じゃないのさすが
に今日は休みなさい
はいゲームでもやるか
あれこれなんかやばい
ぞてか本当に風引いたらずる休みじゃない
じゃん完全変装ダミ作戦つまりダミーの俺
を用意し学校をさぼる学校行ってきます
うんいっ
てらっしゃいいただきます
[音楽]
[拍手]
おしいかおいしいよ
お兄ちゃん言うと1つ頼み事があるんだ
けど何俺に走して学校に行ってほしいんだ
いくら100円でどうだ
任せろ頑張って
お兄ちゃん出を取りますはいはいはい
お前声どうしたんだちょっと声がわりって
やつれそれじゃあここの問題
をやすお前天才なんだから先生の代わりに
説明して
みろえっとわりさんってのはつまり悪こと
ないよ
あ8を4人で分けるとすると僕は大食いだ
から84は8なん
よ
お前トじゃねえ
かユトがすぐにばれることは想定済みここ
からが本番
だすいません遅れましたましたえ
[音楽]
先生え
えどういうこと
だか生徒に触れることは暴剤に与し5年
以下の懲役もしくは30000万円以下の
罰金に問われますなく生に触れることは防
台に与し5年以下の懲役もしくは
300万円以下の罰金にわれますそっか
じゃあ触れなきゃいいだ
なああ
ああお前が解だっ
てはいやらす君のお母さんやらすが学校に
来てないみたいなんですけどはうちの息子
なら朝学校
[音楽]
にちょっと確認してみます家にいるん
でしょ金助早くなさいいないわね靴履か
ないで学校行ったってこと
かしら靴の置き忘れなんてボンミスだどう
すればもういいわ付け
[音楽]
付け
わあこのまだとハにされちまう逃げなきゃ
はい
あよいあれあれあれダンボールはあれあれ
どこ
[音楽]
かしらその足元はやつでしょ
ほら学校行くわ
よ次は通学の爆破作戦ここは俺の家と晩
から小学校をつなぐ唯一の橋この橋が爆破
されたとなると学校側も休みにせざ得ない
だろ準備
完了これで先生に電話すれば
もしもし先生いつも通学に使ってる橋が
壊れてしまったので今日は学校に行けませ
んなんだっ
てちょっと待っ
てろ校長先生数学に使う橋が壊れて投稿
できない生徒がありますなるほど
自用ジェットを配しよう自用ジェット今
そっちに手配してる10分ほどで到着する
だろうありがとうございます気をつけて
くるんじゃぞ
校長の野郎余計なことしやがっ
[音楽]
てはい今日は小学歴史についてお話をして
いきますこうなったらいよいよ学校るしか
ない
な俺がに開発をしていたスクール
[音楽]
ンバー
わしもなめられたもんじゃ
な敵型レーザー光成クルマボール
Xやった
[音楽]
なやた負け
たてるだみなげろあ
[音楽]
うこれじゃしばらく学校には行けないね
生徒君新しく学校を立てたので今日から
そっちで授業を行うぞ
[拍手]
イはいじゃあ今日はバのカオの歴史の曲る
休できなかったなはバ小学校の長先生とし
て知れていますけれ学校はどうだ相変わら
ずつまらないけど校長先生のおかで少し
楽しかったよそりゃよかったこれはす君
あての手紙だはねどう思わ兵県のに生まれ
た万先生は年収が200万円
のまし
た学校回避
10兆やっ
[音楽]
も
ちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録
よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル登録ま
チャンネル
登録